a very different experience from filming
Game of Thrones which is a little while
ago now for you tell me a little bit
about that what is like filming with Kit
Harington and people like the one being
yeah I think I think it was kind of like
being with a family I mean we went out
to shoot the pilot initially so we'd all
bonded there and I just really remember
too Sean beans that I went up to him
said oh I'm playing your brother he says
yes I hear oh god he's not going to like
me very much and then that night we're
going to play pool and I beat him and he
sort of leaned on my shoulder that's my
brother so and it kind of set off like
that so we kind of found our our places
with each other and Kip was kind of like
the little brother you know one they
want to take care of and make sure he's
all right and Anibal he is very open and
really sweet sweet land wonderful actor
and gave me a lot of place to stand
there and be his uncle baby which is
right how much would you like to see
Benjen return I think we should see what
happens it'd be lovely to venture in
return in some form another whether that
will happen or not remains down to
george RR martin who a wonderful man and
we'll see if he writes that story if it
comes to fruition then then it would be
great to take that
you